les personnes sous surveillance au
québec n'ont finalement pas le
coronavirus il n'y a donc aucun nouveau
code coronavirus pour l'instant au
québec ni au canada
à peine quelques semaines après
l'éclosion en chine
les laboratoires canadiens peuvent déjà
déterminé en 24 heures
si une personne est infectée ou non ce
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'on ait
eu la séquence génétique
on a donc la possibilité de faire des
tests très rapidement suffit d'un
prélèvement de salive et vérifier si les
données du patient correspondent au
virus le genre d'outil qui n'existaient
pas durant la crise du strass en 2003 ce
qui permet au personnel médical de
réagir plus vite d'endiguer plus
rapidement une éventuelle éclosion au
pays comparativement à ce qu'on a vécu
au du temps du strass on est à des
années-lumière d'amélioration si la
technologie est là on reste toujours sur
le qui vive pour le moment québec on est
vigilant on ne dort pas sur la soute
un deuxième cas d'infection au
coronavirus a été déclarée aux états
unis il s'agit d'une sexagénaire revenus
de buran le 13 janvier la femme qui
habite chicago se porte bien elle n'a
pas pris les transports en commun et a
eu très peu de contacts depuis son
retour de chine
c'est normal avec le nom de transport
qui elle en longue qui tarde de la chine
qu'au moment donné il ya un coq qui
arrive
la chine de son côté renforce des
mesures préventives c'est maintenant 40
millions de chinois qui sont confinés
dans leur ville
je pense que ça démontre l'importance
que la chine accorde essayer de contenir
la situation dans son pays
la chine va même construire en dix jours
un hôpital dédié au corona virus pouvant
accueillir jusqu'à 1000 patients
si la situation se détériore ici vincent
maisonneuve race au canada montréal